aquí tenemos una caja miniatura de
cereal la variable aleatoria x
representa el peso del cereal en la caja
la empresa que produce este cereal hace
millones de estas cajas por lo que
tienen un valor esperado del peso del
cereal en la caja digamos que este es 16
gramos es común ver ese tipo de
información impresa en la caja pero no
significa que todas las cajas tengan
exactamente 16 gramos de cereal existen
ciertas incertidumbres como la densidad
de las hojuelas de cereal la forma en
que el cereal es vertido en la caja el
tamaño y peso de las hojuelas todo esto
puede ocasionar una diferencia en el
peso en este ejemplo diremos que la
varianza de x es igual a 0.64 gramos es
lo que puede variar el peso del cereal
en la caja porque no siempre pesará
exactamente 16 gramos de forma similar
supongamos que tenemos un tazón pequeño
con cereal y tenemos la variable
aleatoria que representa el peso del
cereal en el tazón también tenemos un
valor esperado para esta variable
aleatoria digamos que en promedio el
valor esperado o la media del peso del
cereal que cabe en este
es de 4 gramos de forma similar tenemos
una varianza de la variable aleatoria y
que depende del tamaño de las hojuelas
de cómo vierten el cereal y qué tanto
quieren llenar el tazón
digamos que la varianza de g es de 0.36
gramos
con esta información definida veamos la
suma y la diferencia de estas variables
aleatorias supongamos que tenemos una
nueva variable aleatoria que es igual a
la suma de las variables xy es la
variable aleatoria z hemos visto en
vídeos anteriores que el valor esperado
de la suma de dos variables aleatorias
es la suma del valor esperado de cada
una de las variables aleatorias esto
tiene sentido porque si queremos conocer
el peso del cereal de la caja más el
cereal del tazón esperaremos que sea 16
gramos más 4 gramos o sea 20 gramos de
forma similar
si queremos conocer la diferencia de
peso entre el cereal de la caja y el
cereal del tazón esperaríamos que fuera
igual a la diferencia entre estos
valores pero en esta ocasión vamos a
hablar sobre la varianza cuál será la
varianza de la
aleatoria x más la variable aleatoria y
a que creen que sea igual resulta que
sumamos las varianzas de cada variable
aleatoria siempre y cuando estas
variables sean realmente independientes
es decir la probabilidad de tener cierto
peso en este tazón no depende del peso
del cereal que tengamos en esta caja
escribimos suponemos independencia más
adelante veremos con un ejemplo por qué
es importante esta independencia esto
tiene sentido porque si aquí tenemos
cierta incertidumbre que podemos medir
con la varianza y tenemos otra
incertidumbre aquí y la sumamos también
sumaremos las incertidumbres que se
miden con la varianza ahora veamos una
pregunta interesante qué pasaría si
tuviéramos una variable aleatoria que
fuera igual a la diferencia de estas
variables aleatorias a que será igual
esta varianza cuando hablamos del valor
esperado
simplemente calculamos la diferencia
entre los valores esperados de las
variables pero resulta que para calcular
la varianza vamos a sumar las varianzas
de las variables aleatorias
una forma de pensar en esto es que si
tenemos una incertidumbre aquí y otra
incertidumbre acá no importa si sumamos
o restamos las incertidumbres siempre se
van a sumar para comprender mejor esto
pensemos que aquí tenemos una caja
aleatoria de nuestro cereal la abrimos y
vemos que el cereal tiene un peso
promedio de 16 gramos además tenemos un
tazón vacío que en promedio tiene una
capacidad de 4 gramos después vertemos
el cereal en el tazón la cantidad de
cereal que ponemos en el tazón es
completamente independiente de la
cantidad de el peso original del cereal
que existe en la caja en este caso x -
representa la cantidad de cereal que
queda en la caja pensemos en la
variabilidad está la variabilidad con la
que comenzamos y también depende de
quién vierta el cereal como lo esté
vertiendo o la forma en la que caen las
hojuelas
así que agregamos más varianza otra
forma de encuadrar esto es pensar en
términos de la desviación estándar
recuerden que la varianza es la
desviación estándar al cuadrado
escribir esto como la desviación
estándar al cuadrado de la combinación
de dos variables aleatorias es igual a
la suma de los cuadrados de las
desviaciones estándar de cada variable
la desviación estándar al cuadrado de la
variable x más la desviación estándar al
cuadrado de la variable y esto puede
parecerles familiar si es que conocen el
teorema de pitágoras donde sea al
cuadrado es igual a b al cuadrado más a
al cuadrado es por eso que a esto se le
llama el teorema pitagórico de la
estadística de hecho hay varias formas
interesantes de pensar en esto como en
un triángulo rectángulo si tenemos dos
variables que son realmente
independientes entre sí para un
triángulo rectángulo debemos tener un
ángulo de 90 grados entre dos lados y en
este caso debemos tener independencia
entre las variables por lo que hay
formas de conectar estas ideas
geométricamente pero podemos ver aquí
que no sumamos desviaciones estándar
sino que sumamos desviaciones estándar
al cuadrado o sumamos las varianzas es
importante tener esto en mente en
resumen para expresar esta segunda parte
cuando queremos encontrar
la varianza de la diferencia de dos
variables vamos a sumar la varianza de
cada variable regresando a este ejemplo
en cualquier caso ya sea una caja
completa de cereal más el cereal en un
tazón lleno la varianza de la suma será
la suma de las varianzas en este caso
será 0.64 + 0.36 así que la varianza de
x + d es igual a un gramo y esto es
igual en el otro caso cuando nos
interesa encontrar la varianza de la
diferencia de x
no importa que restamos las variables la
incertidumbre o la variabilidad se
siguen sumando si queremos expresar esta
misma idea en términos de la desviación
estándar la desviación estándar de
nuestra variable x es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de esto 0.8 gramos y la
desviación estándar de nuestra variable
que es igual a 0.6 gramos
sustituimos los valores al cuadrado de
las desviaciones estándar y al sumarlas
obtenemos un gramo que es nuestra
varianza si sacamos la raíz cuadrada de
esto obtendremos la desviación estándar
de x
que en este caso es un gramo noten que
esto no es igual a la suma de estos
otros 21 no es igual a la suma de 0.8
más 0.6 pero si sumamos los cuadrados de
ambos tendremos 1 al cuadrado y con esto
terminamos